Michael avenatti the lawyer for an adult
film star allegedly paid off by
President Trump faces a felony charge of
domestic violence
police arrested avenatti in Los Angeles
yesterday he was freed on bail avenatti
told reporters the charge is false and
he expects to be cleared
I have never struck a woman I never will
strike a woman I have been an advocate
for women's rights my entire career and
I'm going to continue to be an advocate
police say an incident on Tuesday left
the alleged victim with visible injuries
a vanadis estranged ex-wife Lisa story
avenatti denied initial reports that
identified her as the victim in a
statement she said that there has never
been any domestic violence in their
relationship
president Trump is openly speculating
about replacing cabinet members he told
the Daily Caller were looking at options
including replacing Homeland Security
Secretary Kirsten Nelson the president
says he expect to make that decision
shortly press secretary Sarah Sanders
said deputy national security adviser
Mira Ricardo will transition to a new
role within the administration
McArdle as you have heard his clash with
staffers of the first lady and defense
secretary that prompted the first lady's
office to issue an extraordinary
statement calling for her dismissal how
about that transition we'll find out
where she ends up but if you're not
gonna be in the White House you know the
word transition is always an interesting
word to see how that really turns out
especially interesting given that the
first lady had never even met Mara
personally yeah